for a long time there had been
rumors that the two girls hadn't quite
clicked
you had headlines of the dueling
duchesses
they just didn't have very much in
common i was always told that there was
never a cat fight as such between the
two girls i was told there hadn't been a
fallout over anything
specific i was told that they simply
didn't
click that they didn't have a huge
amount in common
and this seems to be reinforced in the
book that apparently kate felt they had
nothing more in common than the fact
that they lived
at the same palace megan by all accounts
had hoped that
kate would show her the ropes i think in
fairness to the cambridges they did make
certain attempts to to befriend megan
they
invited her out for drinks they
obviously hosted the couple
the christmas after their engagement
where apparently
kate made an effort in the kitchen to
cook megan's favorite vegan meals
clearly the cambridges feel that they
did try but obviously megan and harry
feel that they didn't
try enough and i was told from a source
very close to prince harry that they
didn't feel they had rolled out the red
carpet
so it was therefore very interesting to
read reports this weekend
contesting the claims and finding
freedom that megan and harry didn't feel
they had been welcoming enough
that the cambridges felt that they had
rolled out the red carpet
and so you're clearly hearing two
different sides of the story
from two different camps william and
kate feel that they did go out of their
way to make megan feel welcome
particularly that first christmas
inviting them into the sanctity of
animal hall something they don't do for
anyone
um and then megan and harry feeling that
they could have done a lot more
uh you know there were flowers sent to
megan on her birthday for example
kate would have felt that that was a
lovely gesture apparently megan felt it
wasn't enough
one of the stories explored in the book
is the story that
megan apparently made kate pryor at a
bridesmaid fitting for
princess charlotte it was a story that
was certainly doing the rounds and did
end up being reported
in numerous papers but the book at least
tries
to knock it on its head by claiming that
actually it wasn't true
according to the authors megan didn't
make kate cry
working together as family do you ever
have disagreements about things
oh yes we start together for the rest of
our lives so
this is true togetherness togetherness
yeah yeah
megan and harry felt that it was them
against the palace against william and
kate
um appoints i think against his own
father
and they have been labeled professional
victims
in the press it's fascinating just to
see or to hear this story through their
perspective
we wanted a happy ending for this couple
and
i think i think there is a great sadness
that it hasn't been
that the happy ending that people wanted
it's clear in finding freedom that there
is still so much
hurt so many raw emotions so many
um relationships that need to be fixed
and i don't think they're there yet
you